hey y'all I'm Darius Rucker and I'm here
to answer the internet this episode of
antsy internet is brought to you by bare
bottom clothing stick around after the
episode for more details is eating in
bed gross no
you better be eating in bed
I made her laugh
she's like you're damn right who is the
worst group of fans in sports oh the
worst group of fans will probably be
Jets fans because they always think
they're going to win something and
they're not
hahaha
it ain't this year brother that's true
if you were taking hostage five years
ago what what surprised you most about
the world today oh it would be like the
domination of how streaming it has
become what it is like five years ago I
was I kept going ah we're gonna they're
gonna figure it out they haven't figured
it out
if you could put in franchise restaurant
in your house what would it be all that
it's a great question but if I can put
any franchise restaurant in my house it
would probably
oh Taco Bell
absolutely Taco Bell
Taco Bell talk about Mexican pizza and I
got this Taco Bell on my house has also
got a KFC so I got a Mexican pizza and a
chicken pot pie
thousand degrees I burn my mouth every
time like I gotta let it sit for like 10
minutes love it do you think there are
more porn stars or murderers in the
world
uh murderers because who's paying for
porn today come on who's paying for them
who are the guys paying for porn
free on the internet
what is the fiercest animal you think
you could take in a fight oh
the fiercest animal I could take in a
fight probably I think I could take a
bobcat because they're not that big then
I can fight one that's about as fish as
I get anything bigger than a bobcat I'm
out okay that's a real answer that's
Carolina boys yeah yeah play have
children before yeah I saw one
if any time you wanted to eat an animal
you had to kill it yourself would you
still eat meat oh yeah yeah I've eaten
animals I've killed before I we eat
animals I kill again absolutely we
usually ask this to like comedians from
Brooklyn the guy from South Carolina
yeah
would you rather be drunk 24 7 or never
be drunk again man I'll just start this
by saying I partied my whole life for a
long time but I still think I'd rather
be drunk 24 7. and not be drunk again
yeah you can keep like a healthy body
yeah yeah exactly I can live with that
you can write it back up when you want I
can live with that if your girl had to
wear a mascot head during sex for the
rest of your life which one would you
choose she would definitely be wearing a
South Carolina Gamecock cocky hat and
I'll be kissing her on that boat
would you rather lose half your dick's
length or half your dick's girth
definitely the length
yeah you gotta like despair yeah
[Laughter]
every time you finish sex a song played
what song would it be oh good question
what song would I want it to be if every
time I finish sex what song would I want
it to be
All of Me by John Legend oh
that's definitely
this last question is brought to you by
bear bottom bare Bottom's newly expanded
line of comfortable yet stylish and cozy
clothes brings the air everyday wear to
the next level they had tons of new
lines to explore from the suprema soft
tee to the Cabana Camp collar shirt Camp
collars are everywhere you need to get
one right now wear wash and repeat with
bare bottoms comfy stretch clothing that
works for everyone from a cross City
dweller to a cross-country hiker it
doesn't matter who you are or what you
are bare bottoms clothing is perfect for
you it is a perfect fit it is the
perfect Comfort level it is everything
you need wearable washable repeatable
doesn't stretch out in the doesn't
stretch doesn't shrink in the laundry
doesn't stretch out on your body it's
perfect for everything and on top of all
that with bare bottom you could be a
good person not many clothings not many
clothing brands offer you that you can
be a good person because for each item
you purchase bare bottom will donate a
meal to a kid in need that is right you
can feed the needy with
while also feeding your closet so go to
barebottom.com ATI right now and get
free shipping on your first order that's
barebottom.com ATI right now free
shipping on your first order would you
switch your penis size with your foot
size
[Music]
when I go to the airport I got a fake
knee so I can't go through the regular I
can go through the every time
every time
every time every time
she wears boxes are too small
[Laughter]
dude I know I just go
every time
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out